the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
this was a story i could have covered
earlier on in sort of the process i
guess we would call it but i didn't and
it's i guess kind of starting to wrap up
or it's probably going to this is the
story of Secretary of Health and Human
Services Tom Price using private jets
for i-s what we would call personal
travel and initially once it was sort of
announced or learned that Tom price had
been all wrapped up with using private
government or rather government jets for
his personal travel one of the arguments
that was made was well he needs to have
access to secure communications and it's
much easier if he's traveling with a
government jet than not and although it
may well be true that it's easier it's
not clear for him it's not clear at all
that it's cheaper than just arranging
for secure travel with him traveling on
commercial airliners rather than
chartering an entire jet from the
government for his personal trips and
Politico reported that he had charted
chartered a bunch of these flights at a
very significant cost to the federal
government of course he claims he wants
to cut costs and part of his plan for
getting rid of Obamacare was all about
cutting costs and of course it might
have cut costs to insurance companies
but it would have done it at an
increased cost to actual consumers of
health care in the United States and
Politico says that it identified at
minimum four hundred thousand dollars in
spending on private jets and of course
you see two arguments with this very
often when we talk about a government
program it's the right who says we can't
afford it and you will sometimes be able
to argue accurately that well this might
be the cost for the program but here's
the savings that you would get from
other programs this is one of those
times where people defending price are
saying hey it's only $400,000 after all
all of a sudden they don't care about it
because it's an amount of money they
don't consider to be significant at
particularly when there are very little
savings
- having priced charter these Jets all
over the country and the world yeah
that's a pretty good amount of money
four hundred thousand dollars and twenty
six flights especially we could have
just flown commercially and I understand
I think all secretaries should have
Secret Service protection sure and you
know in the past maybe someone wouldn't
know who a Secretary of Health and Human
Services but in this case you do because
of his attempts to repeal the Affordable
Care Act more people more people know
who Tom prices so he does need
protection but he shouldn't be taking
these private jets I mean that's just
ludicrous
do you agree that the Secretary of State
is like the most high-profile of the
secretaries I think so right yeah we go
with state defense I think it correlates
pretty much with that presidential
succession chart yeah I guess you know I
guess you're right where is Ben Carson
on this thing he's pretty low end he's
lower than Tom Price oh absolutely yes I
think Health and Human Services I mean
is been around longer oh yeah
development and actually I think last on
the list was the most newest of the
newest department which is Homeland
Security oh that would be higher was
that position created after 9/11 yes it
was oh yeah okay so anyway Tom Price I I
guess he wants to save money but not on
airfare that's the one area where he
says it's worth spending more apparently
and you know the guys were 13 million
dollars I think a lot of these people
are you coming from industries where
they're really successful yeah like you
know in the Newton's case he was in
Goldman Sachs or a lot of these people
were CEO so they were used to having
jobs that had these great perks like
being able to fly around in private
planes and maybe they just don't
understand yeah you can't really do that
in government he can afford the main
cabin extra for 90 bucks on American
Airlines right I mean I think that
that's that's something that that's
within his budget 13 million dollars can
get you pretty far and you know minuchin
did pretty much the same thing here at
least I wanted to and I there was
actually a thing I read about minuchin
'he's wife who I guess is an actress
maybe from the UK or something like that
she posted a picture on her Instagram
where they were getting off of a
government plane and it was very clear
she had like I think he had shopping
bags with her they were clearly on some
kind of personal trip and it exploded
also and I think she's either like taken
her Instagram account private since then
or maybe deleted that picture I don't
know
yeah they claim they're going to
Kentucky to check out like the gold
reserves
oh yeah it just so happened to coincide
with the solar cliff so they met up with
Mitch McConnell and you know they're
kind of on the way literally a grand old
party I would say right okay let's talk
about what's going on with Whole Foods
and Amazon Whole Foods was purchased by
Amazon they are now offering one-hour
wine delivery in many big cities to
prime customers and Amazon now is
announcing something else which is big
which is that they are going to partner
with a company called Ollo which
provides food ordering software to the
restaurant industry and they are going
to try to start doing very fast delivery
of Chipotle and other fast food and I'm
not loving this I'm not huge yeah I'm
not that into this they're gonna do
Shake Shack Applebee's
listen nobody should be going to
Applebee's period in big cities I
understand there are parts of the
country that are food deserts if you
want to go out to eat you might only
have as an option McDonald's and Burger
King and then if you want something a
little nicer Olive Garden and Applebee's
I understand that but in cities there is
no reason that anyone should be going to
Applebee's or Chili's or whatever and
this is not an economic thing because
those restaurants are just as expensive
as many local city places so this is not
a question of economic elitism or
anything like that whatsoever I just
think that it would be great if Amazon
wanted to bring home delivered food or
work delivered food whatever forward to
the next stage the next paradigm don't
do it with chains like Applebee's well
what if you're sitting on your couch and
you want a Chipotle burrito with
guacamole yeah and you also want a
smoothie from Jamba Juice I mean what
are gonna do drive to both locations no
it's not you get both of them from your
local New York or Boston area deli where
they have all of that stuff and they'll
make you whatever you want you just go
in and ask that's what you do you don't
go and get it from Applebee's or those
other places I don't like this and
listen is this a parent issue of
paramount importance not really but I do
think that the entire fast food craze in
the u.s. is a major problem and the last
thing we want to be doing is making it
even
easier for people to sit on their couch
and get 64 ounce sodas and and low-grade
meats delivered to them yeah and how
about corporate consolidation now too I
mean you can be reading The Washington
Post on your Kindle and use Alexa to
order this Chipotle and Jamba Juice that
you want it's all coming through Amazon
delivered by Ollo partnered with Amazon
right and then you watch the TV that you
ordered through Prime when right what
gets delivered to you or whatever yeah
so I don't like it it's not this this is
not going to make or break the obesity
crisis in the United States I think that
that's that's pretty clear at this point
but I'm not loving this and you know
when Amazon is huge and I think with any
company as big as Amazon or Facebook or
Microsoft companies that regularly buy
smaller companies you're definitely
going to be able to find different
subsidiary companies that are sort of in
direct conflict with each other in terms
of values right like at the same time
that Amazon is gonna have this
partnership with Ollo to deliver fast
food to people's homes they have
partnerships through Amazon fresh with
local organic food providers to get you
local organic food through Amazon fresh
which would seem to be sort of directly
at odds with each other but these
companies are huge it's sort of
inevitable I think well maybe it's like
that thing that people put on their
Twitter profiles like retweets are not
necessarily endorsement yeah companies
try to distance themselves from it all
companies we own are not necessarily
reflective of our values or something
like that I don't know anyway that's
what's that's the latest with Amazon
okay I I had a period where I was
feeling potentially incredibly guilty
because when the Equifax breach well not
when it took place because it took place
back in July but when we learned about
it a couple of weeks ago I came to you
and I said there is a website Equifax
security 2017 dot-com and on that
website you can verify whether or not
your personal financial information
might have been breached or affected and
I learned a few days ago that for a
while Equifax on Twitter was directing
people to a fake site an actual phishing
site a malicious web site they were
directing people to a web site that
supposedly was
to help you figure out whether your data
had been breached in the Equifax scandal
but it was actually a fake site and I
thought that on the on the day we did
the story that we might have been
linking to the fake site but it turns
out we weren't so the fake site is
security
Equifax 2017 dot-com which is very
similar to the real site which is
Equifax security 2017 comm fortunately
we were linking to the real site which
by the way was also allegedly
misconfigured and had its own security
risks that we ultimately found out about
an insane story but it at least was the
real Equifax site and not security
Equifax 2017 which was a straight-up
phishing website and somehow there were
Equifax staffers tweeting to the
malicious web site telling people on
this website you can figure out if you
were affected yeah I remember a lot of
people even when it comes to the
legitimate website we're a little bit
concerned there those who entered your
name and I think the last six numbers of
your social security number
exactly we're mean meaning that you
leave out the first three but then when
you think about it like there's only a
thousand possible combinations of your
social security number that it's like a
hacker could possibly run through it
yeah if they get access to that
information once you give if the last
six of your social and your full name
were to be accessed you could relatively
quickly with some relatively simple
computer programs start to come across
valid social security numbers I think is
the idea right but anyway at least that
wasn't a totally fake website and it's
going really bad I actually spoke to
some attorneys late last week and they
told me confidentially that a lot of law
firms are looking at the best way to
approach this and their instinct was
that it's going to happen as a
class-action right and that the class
actions often end up disproportionately
benefiting lawyers because they said
that as individuals it's going to be
tough to sue Equifax unless you can show
specific damages like my information was
potentially breached when I checked it
out on the website it said yes it
appears that your information was
breached or may have or may have a
message but so far I've not had my
identity stolen there have not been a
pounce opened in my name so I haven't
really suffered any damages and what the
lawyers I spoke to said was that unless
you've suffered some kind of damages
that it's it's gonna be very tough to
actually sue Equifax successfully if
that's the approach you want to take so
that more than likely only in the most
extreme cases of significant financial
loss due to the breach with someone do
an individual lawsuit and that more than
likely this will end up being one of
those class actions where you might end
up getting you know twenty bucks yeah
that's what I was thinking because what
a hundred and fifty million or so people
were affected by this nearly half of the
country so even if there was a
class-action lawsuit and they had to pay
like a billion dollar penalty right it's
not even gonna add up to that much even
if everyone makes a stake in that claim
yeah because I think if you think 150
million people if everybody got two
dollars that would be 300 million
dollars if everybody gets twenty dollars
you're already talking about a three
billion dollar settlement and if indeed
the attorneys end up keeping twenty to
thirty percent of that that's a big
major payday for them but I think you
would have to be proactive in joining
the suit would you not yeah I I mean you
never would do that usually when that
happens you do get something sent to you
which says we believe you may have been
impacted by this breach we're the law
firm of such-and-such we're handling
this whatever I once actually was party
to a class-action lawsuit a successful
one where I had years ago I had a Honda
Civic Hybrid and the window sticker you
know how when you go and get a car the
window sticker tells you what the gas
mileage is expected to be right and when
you compared the Civic Hybrid to the
Civic non-hybrid the Civic Hybrid window
sticker was a pretty significantly
higher gas mileage and it turned out
that that was very much exaggerated so a
lot of people decided to spend something
more I leased it so it was a very small
difference but if you were to have
bought the hybrid might have been
fifteen hundred or twenty five hundred
dollars more than the non hybrid and
because of the inaccurate gas mileage
representation you actually would not
have saved money on an overall due to
higher gas mileage unless you drove
something like sixty thousand miles per
year or something like that some people
are buying one particular model of the
car thinking that it's going to save
them money in the long term so if it
doesn't actually end up saving that
money exact then they got ripped off or
at least they feel that way but
apparently the difference was not that
huge and it was a successful class
action
I filled out the paperwork and I got a
check for $100 that's a good night out
it's a good it's a it's a good night out
and at least I ended up not coming out
behind with the entire hybrid thing but
yeah it's like the gas mileage wasn't
that great civics get great gas mileage
anyway yeah I feel like you already
fudged those numbers to begin with
because you may be talking about like
city miles versus highway miles I mean
there's so many variables when it comes
to that so to mess up on something like
that they really messed up big big
problem a Honda ended up hanging out all
right that's it for bonus show elections
for the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]